lucas je disais un départ prévu dans
quelques instants pour cette
manifestation parisienne
y at il du monde il y à quelques
dizaines de personnes pour l'instant ici
à paris place du palais royal emmené
devant le conseil d'état
les manifestations vont commencer les
ponots ont donné lorsque le but est
notamment
[Musique]
ce qu'ils appellent une loi liberticide
le jeu justement
on dirait que l'intérêt de cette
manifestation jouit de cette
mobilisation c'est leur fusion mot
d'ordre de pour toujours lutter contre
ces lois liberticides comprend de mettre
en place le président en place et de
pouvoir apporter un message de soutien à
l'ensemble des strips mehdi qui sont
aujourd'hui au sein des manifestations
et qui prennent très cher de la part des
forces de police à se faire confisquer
leur matériel
je m'appelle sont des gens qui viennent
aider en cas de blessures et de
problèmes sur la manifestation est aussi
apporter leur soutien à l'ensemble des
médias indépendants aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont une autre vision une autre
information à donner que celle des
médias meanstream et qui aussi prennent
très cher en terme de répression de la
part de gouvernements et des services de
police
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur le virage
sécuritaire de manuel mac os x
gouvernement remet ça fait deux ans que
ça dure on est quelque part un petit peu
les les responsables de cette situation
à a empêché macron de pouvoir dérouler
son programme présidentiel et le fait de
ne pas pouvoir penser à la vitesse qu'il
veut il met en place des lois qui nous
empêchent aujourd'hui de pouvoir
manifester de pouvoir s'exprimer pour se
rencontrer et surtout de romantique est
allé à l'encontre de tout ce qui est de
toute cette politique mise en place par
le gouvernement
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la loi
séparatisme en tout cas le projet de loi
séparatisme qui est en train d
est-ce que vous manifestez aussi contre
cela alors il ya une part d'importance
maintenant j'ai envie de me prononcer
sur des sujets que je ne maîtrise pas 1
il ya assez d'experts dans différents
plateaux pour pouvoir parler de tout et
de rien et surtout de beaucoup de choses
donc c'est pas quelque chose dans
laquelle je me suis intéressé mais c'est
encore des lois qui vont encore aller à
l'encontre de ce que pour autant
représenter la france de la multi
université du melting-pot français je
pense qu'il est
cette prévision est très simple donnant
du travail aux gens de nom de quoi se
nourrir de non loin un salaire
convenable pour que les gens puissent y
être moins préoccupés par l'avenir de
leur frigo à la fin du mois et pouvoir
s'intéresser justement aux uns ou aux
autres et on fera on fera au jeu gagnera
si tu veux en intelligence à
s'intéresser aux uns et aux autres pour
pouvoir apprendre d'eux et d'arrêter de
d'avoir des parties prier et surtout du
racisme par exemple merci beaucoup je
brillais et bien cette manifestation
maintenant elle se met en marche
elle se dirige vers assemblée nationale
où vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure un
autre appel à manifester a été lancé à
14 heures cette fois ci contre les
licenciements et les suppressions
d'emplois
lucas merci pour toutes ces précisions